[Applaudissements]
après on fera qui a la meilleure bien
c'est le bouder times bouder sur la
série mais c'est un mec qui veut gagner
gloser il réfléchit dit comment je vais
faire pour gagner de l'argent
ouais et un matin il se réveille dit
c'est beau je sais ce que je vais faire
je vais vendre des bibles mais bible dit
mais je vais pas les vendre moi je suis
pas un bon vendeur
je vais organiser un casting et j'ai je
prends deux mecs pour les vendre donc il
arrive dans son casting a que deux
personnes qui sont venues un bègue est
un mec qui parle normalement a dit
madiba je vous embauche faso et à
personne d'autre je vous embauche un
mois après le mec qui parle normalement
a vendu 5 bible et lebègue
il en a vendu 27 waouh c'est pourquoi
fort et il appelle le bain j'ai dit
comment tu fais toi pour vendre tebib et
des eaux
un coq à l'apport rouvre jeudi bon bon
bon bon bon bon bon soir est-ce que je
vous vous vous est-ce que je vous vends
une bible où je vous lis un passage
[Applaudissements]
c'était la première du goût des retards
il démarre très fort ça là je l'adoré
well et bien je la donne j'adore quand
tout allait bien en faire son blouson
fini alors je vous explique jamel parce
que d'habitude d'un explique les
blousons et les vols ou à moi ou à jamel
et là c'est vous non c'est encore un vol
non bien nous voilà j'ai été chercher
mon fils à l'école il avait un petit kit
cities et accroche ses toiles une
deuxième pour le bouder times il en fera
trois de suite à chanter 3-2 cyber
taghmaoui et après on va faire qu'elle a
plus qu elle a commencé fort voilà
comment cette famille quand même le
niveau est très élevé alors c'est un mec
qui n'arrive pas à dormir il dort pas
toute la nuit il dort pas une marche
dans son salon a pris marchi niro fou et
sa femme est en train de dormir
ils empêchent sa femme de dormir
tellement il n'était pas bien et ce afin
d' un moment donné se révèlerait ce qui
t'arrive davézieux qu'est ce qui
m'arrive kitty qu'on égrène les
dimanches dit oui alors dévié bas demain
ce lundi
et oui et alors ça va pas changer sa vie
bat demain lundi on est le vin est dit
oui le vin et loue le problème des
balles 20
tu sais très bien que je dois rendre
deux cent mille euros à mon voisin
michael qui en face le dit alors libère
je les ai pas je n'arrive pas à dormir
et sa fameuse j'attends elle a tout cas
la fenêtre alors ouvert sa fenêtre à la
criée michael méga le droit quoi
lundi mme maryse m'a donné deux cent
mille demain annuaire nibali l'un pas à
l'affirmer apporter 10 d'or maintenant
c'est lui qui va pas dormir
[Applaudissements]
après bien sûr temprano dans la soirée
mais voilà un couple uni
mais si vous êtes très bon montant des
aides attendues à la zorro bernard tout
le monde attendait on attendait john
eledjam et dans ma plein à la c1 mais
qu'il en train de pleurer ils pleurent
rient pleurent rient pleurer à son pote
il vient le voir et demi qu'elle
pourquoi tu pleures dieu pourquoi je
pleure ça fait trente ans que je suis
mariée avec la même femme ne dit alors
c'est bien et dire oui mais ça fait 30
ans que une fois par mois
elle demande 680 euros ou tuera [ __ ]
c'est pas possible
mais qu'est ce qu'elle sait que tout cet
argent ne digère pas je n'ai jamais
donné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]